so hopefully that splitter will be
biting tonight
as he and the braves take the field
tukey back to work with a 2-2 pitch
and strike three right down peachtree
and how about that impressive start jeff
three up three down for tucson there's
the first braves base runner and now
he's in the soup with freddie freeman
standing in on two
freddie got jammed and skies that toward
right vigio going back look at that ball
carry out near the wall it's over his
head it's over the wall freddie freeman
hits a two-run homer and the braves jump
on pearson in the first inning that
looks like a routine fly ball off the
bat and it just kept going going going
gone that gives tookie toussaint an
early lead after one to the second we go
and he just fooled guerrero badly that's
the second strikeout two away yeah so
far so good
swing and a miss everything working for
tukey toussaint three strikeouts and a
two nothing lead nine up and nine down
against the blue jays through the first
three innings including four strikeouts
the shet biggio and guriel will each get
their second look at tucson
first pitch swinging and a fly ball to
deep left and gone
beau beshead with his first home run of
the season went up there looking for a
breaking ball and he got one look how
big his eyes got on that swing he saw
that breaking ball toussaint used it a
lot he tries to throw that get me over
breaking ball and bows all over it
gets that foot down quickly and this is
a no downer deep into the seats over to
third base goes ozuna and he's there
with one out
for adam duvall fly ball toward left
from adam duvall that should be deep
enough curiel with the catch ozuna will
tag and the throw to the plate is going
to be late
abc baseball for atlanta got him on got
him over got him in on a duval sac fly
and the braves do get that toronto run
back
well for this night at least toki
toussaint providing some answers in
rotation for the braves which is hugely
important
the one-two
swing and a miss he just struck out the
side and he's qualified for the win
atlanta leads three to one
five innings and no walks yep
seven strikeouts one shy of tooky's
career high
and he takes care of that eight
strikeouts for toussaint matching a
career high jason try to match his
career high in innings
that high is six he's one strike away
with biggio here it is
and he got it toussaint with nine
strikeouts
a new career high dick of wagis pack
and reese maguire the new battery
and let's see was waggis pack he's not
gonna even throw a pitch he's grabbed
the rosin bag i'm not sure if he was
even on their lineup card because again
the game notes for toronto
said that he was to have been sent
to their alternate training facility
and so i think that's what's happened is
wagus pack is not on the official lineup
card brian snitker is going to come out
and get an explanation here alan porter
has the lineup card out and i think
there was a miscommunication that wagos
pack
was not eligible to pitch in this game
and wag is back all he could do is say
what you mean i can't pitch oh no this
is raphael delis
freddie there's that opposite field pop
and guerrielle lost in the lights that's
going to get to the wall freddie's going
to head to second he's going to turn on
the jets he's gonna try it up he's gonna
slam him on and head back to second and
just did get back
that was trouble the moment it left the
bat
and guriel was
in no man's land and jeff what a
terrifying feeling that must be double
and a wild pitch has freeman at third
base
line to right bisho makes a terrific
catch
saving a run
and elise is going to hang around and
thank cabinet biggio for that play good
defense
and toronto is going to have him at
second and third with no body out
on the ground left side that'll get a
run home
runner holds it second there's the first
out give guerrero an rbi it's a 3-2 game
jammed him roller to third gritrik
swings the first pitch they do that a
lot as we told you two outs that's going
to be the end of the night so tyler
matsik comes in for what has been a
brilliant atlanta bullpen
up the middle and through a base hit
and tolez is rounding third challenging
the arm and will beat the throw to the
plate and the game is tied on a pinched
rbi single by tay oscar hernandez
i think is 043. well it wouldn't be
something if he ended the game
with a long ball in his first game back
as a starter
don't put it past him fly ball deep
toward right field that ball is going to
go
nick marquez walks us off on the first
pitch you call it partner nick
marcheka's first pitch ambushes hits it
into the chop house seats the braves win
the series